A forma mais inteligente que você tem de
começar algo não é criando o zero, é
pegar algo que já funciona. Eu fiz isso,
é extrair todo o design system. Eu não
sei se a própria antrópic tem o deles
nesse nível de profundidade, tá? Quando
você faz isso que eu tô mostrando para
você, pegar referências, extrair o
design. MD, você tá pegando algo
validado. Mesmo sem você saber design
como eu sei, você vai conseguir criar
designs como eu crio, ou melhores do que
eu crio, né? Você tá pegando referência
dos melhores, tudo na vida. Inclusive na
parte web, na parte de criação de
qualquer coisa é sobre dados. Então, por
onde tu começa a sala? Eu sempre começo
por uma análise de dados. Depois que eu
fiz análise de dados, eu vou pra análise
de como esses dados vão ser ajustados.
Depois eu vou pensar em como é que eles
vão ser apresentados.
Tem tudo aqui,
paleta de cores,
a parte semântica
e todos os componentes
da Antropic,
ó, todos os componentes antropic e na
versão Dark
e light, né?
Então, o que que você pode fazer aqui
com isso aqui?
Você pode utilizar ele para gerar, ó, eu
gosto, eu eu gosto desse design, eu
queria um design clean,
como é o da do Berrense. Vocês acabaram
de ver, eu alterei, né, o design aqui,
que tava todo escuro, tal. Eu achei até
que tinha ficado feio aquele design. H,
e para esse aqui agora, se eu pedir para
ele, como tá no design system dele, se
eu pedir para ele criar novas páginas,
isso aqui é uma dor gigantesca do
mercado, tá pessoal? Ah, e é uma dor até
minha mesmo minha, porque assim, eu eu
sou aquele cara que lá que sou chato com
design, vocês perceberam, né, o nível de
que eu sou chato de design de olhar
assim, ó, o microbotão.
Ah, e daí meu time vai lá, ele eles us
eles criavam algumas páginas LPG que não
ficavam, por exemplo, usava outra
tipografia. usava uma cor que, por
exemplo, eu defini que é 4C 4C 4C, né, o
RGB lá, o RGB dela, ele usavam tipo 5 4
4E 4B 4E, já muda completamente as
cores. E eu percebo isso. Eh, e para
mesmo quem não percebe isso tão de cara,
quando a gente vai ter todo mundo vai
criando novo site, novas páginas, você
vai ver que daqui a pouco tá ficando
totalmente diferente de tudo. Ah, então
o que que você vai fazer aqui? Eu posso
agora
pedir para ele criar outras páginas, ó.
Vamos botar crie uma página de, ó, crie
ah, uma página,
um dash
completo
de com vários exemplos de gráficos,
tá? E tabelas
para o menu audiência.
Então agora ele vai criar para essa
página que nem existe aqui, ó, ele vai
criar agora vários gráficos e a gente
vai, você vai ver que vai seguir o mesmo
padrão de cores, tá? Até onde o
copyright protege quanto a sites,
não tem como cadastrar, por exemplo,
assim, ah, o Alan, o que que a gente
consegue proteger, né? Eu falo eu como
marca, porque assim, até o meu tá aqui,
ó. Eu coloquei o meu também disponível
para vocês, né? Tá aqui o meu da
academia lendária, tá o meu aqui do EOX.
O que que a gente consegue proteger? Ah,
o nome e a logo. Só isso. Por exemplo, a
Apple não pode proteger que, por
exemplo, tá aqui o da Apple, né? Ah,
quero usar o da Apple. Inclusive, eu
tava lá na Apple semana
passada ou retrasada
passada, eu acho. É, semana passada, eu
tava lá na Apple. H, e conversando
inclusive com o engenheiro de design
deles. Ah,
e cara, eles têm um design system
absurdo pra parte web. Eles não têm isso
visual, você não consegue ver, né? Mas a
Apple tem, você pode pegar ali, eles tem
até no site deles tem a parte de de
apps,
pra parte de software, eles têm algumas
coisas ali que você consegue ver. Mas,
por exemplo, eu posso vir aqui com o pé
o design da Apple, né? É esse aqui que é
o que aqui o o formato de botões, uma
tipografia similar, etc. Não tem. Isso
aqui é uma referência, tá? Aqui, ó,
design inspirado em Apple. Até porque
essas, como é que essas empresas se
protegem também? Ah, elas se protegem
comprando uma fonte que é uma fonte
exclusiva delas e que até o nome da
fonte eles trogam para para elas, né?
Vamos pegar, por exemplo, a Apple aqui.
Daí você não consegue usar essa fonte,
por exemplo, essa fonte aqui da Apple eu
não posso usar. Por quê? Porque ela é
uma fonte que é da Apple, né? Se eu
venho aqui e olho aqui o que foi o que
foi renderizado, SF Pro Text. Ah, é da
Apple, não sei se é deles mesmo. Ah,
algumas empresas não tem, né? Mas você
pode as transições da Apple, né? Essas
essas o paralax que eles utilizam, eh,
etc.,
você pode utilizar igual, não tem
problema nenhum, né? Então, em questão
de de copywriting é isso, só logo não
pode usar, né? No como se você fosse
eles. É alguma coisa assim. Ah, do tem,
é, algumas têm fontes próprias. Ah,
então você não vai conseguir utilizar
aquela fonte que é própria. O Miriam,
por exemplo, tem fonte própria. Eu adoro
a fonte do Miriam.
Eu pesquisei muito para encontrar uma
fonte similar a deles. Eu adoro a fonte
do Miriam.
E que que acontece? Por que que eu isso
a forma mais inteligente que você tem de
começar algo não é criando zero, é pegar
algo que já funciona. Porque, por
exemplo, eu sei que o Miriam investiu
algumas centenas
de milhares de dólares
em teste A B para descobrir qual que é a
tipografia melhor paraa leitura,
espaçamentos paraa leitura. Ah,
espaçamentos de paging, espaçamentos de
margem, espaçamentos
o tamanho de fonte. Você percebe que,
por exemplo, aqui, ó, as imagens são
maiores, mas por que que o texto deles
tá desse tamanho? Porque cansa a leitura
se o texto for muito wide, né, for muito
largo. Por que que você consegue ler
muito mais rápido no celular se você for
ler do que se você pegar um um Kindle,
um iPad, porque o seu olho tem que
correr mais tempo, ele cansa mais. Então
o que acontece quando você faz isso que
eu tô mostrando para você de pegar
referências, extrair o design.md,
você tá pegando algo validado, você
depois pode trocar a cor, mas por, por
exemplo, tem coisa que você vai mexer
que você nem entende do que porque você
tá estragando as coisas.
Ah, por exemplo, pra escrita, o ideal é
a fonte serifada e não serife. Ah, o que
que é isso? siifada é que ela tem essas
porinhas aqui, ó, mais desenhadinhas,
ela não corta. Daí você vem aqui e
perde. Não gostei da da herifada, nem
sabe, você nem sabe esse nome, né? Você
nem sabe o que é serifada. Você
simplesmente fala assim: "Eu não gostei
dessa fonte, eu vou trocar essa fonte,
ó. Vou vir aqui, vou trocar a fonte
aqui.
Fonte family
Ariel.
É, eu gosto mais assim, ó. Tudo bem. As
pessoas vão parar de ler o que tu
escreve porque cansa. Nem a pessoa sabe
porque parou de ler, porque fontes que
são sanserif, elas cansam mais a
leitura. Ah, e daí você tá perdendo
pessoas que leem tuas coisas e tu não
entendeu por quê.
Por isso que é importante quando o que
que é uma, é uma premissa minha, né, uma
heística minha, ah, é não reinventar
roda. Existem empresas que foram lá e
testaram muito para saber qual WCTA é
melhor, ou seja, qual referência de qual
referência de ahã de variação de cores é
ideal para que a pessoa fique mais tempo
na página. Um monte de coisa. Daí você
vai lá e que aí não, eu acho mais bonito
ter um emoji piscando, né? Eh, eu faço
site desde desde os anos 2000 e
pouquinho, 2000 bolinhas. Na na época
que eu fazia site, o pessoal gostava que
eu que eu colocasse gifs ou flash.
Então, tem um gif que é famoso que uma
eu eu e e eu falei uma vez, né, para
meus amigos, só que falta o a única
coisa que falta é um cliente pedir para
ter o gif da bananinha. Para quem é
antigo conhece esse gif aqui, alguém
conhece esse gif? Daí vai entregar idade
aqui.
Deixa eu ver aqui. Alguém digita aqui
que se conhece esse gif aqui.
Esse aqui é antigo. Esse aqui é lá dos
anos 2000.
Então eu faço site lá dos anos 2000 e
pouquinhos, né? 2000 bolinhas. Ah, eu
falei, né? Só falta um cliente pedir
isso aqui, porque os clientes ficavam
pedindo que eu colocasse animação,
gifinho. Nossa, eu quero que no meu site
tem caia, por exemplo, estrelinhas. Eu
quero que tenha um, fique de dia e de
noite e por aí vai, né? Então, eu faço o
site há mais de 20 anos já. Eh, beleza.
Então, entenderam, né, a importância
dessa disso aqui, tá? Agora vamos ver
ali se ele criou.
Pronto, criou aqui, ó.
Criou aqui para mim a parte de
audiência, ó. Olha o design como tá
clean. Olha os espaos espaçamentos, ó.
Tudo bonitinho, os passamentos, as
cores,
padrão
profissional.
Eu abro um site desse aqui, que que eu
vou achar agora? Vocês vão conseguir
enganar os outros, né? Ah,
porque você com que eu tô te entregando
aqui hoje,
mesmo se você saber design como eu sei,
você vai conseguir criar designs como eu
crio, ou melhores do que eu crio, né?
Porque eh você tá pegando referência dos
melhores,
você vai pegar referência dos sites que
você gosta, não precisa ser só um, né?
Você pode mesclar, mas tá vendo que
assim eu não tô copiando o BR, tá vendo?
Bir tá aqui. O Bren é outra coisa. Eu
peguei ele como referência para que
fosse um design clean do meu dashboard.
Agora meu dashboard é clean como beren.
Se eu quiser mudar, não, gostei mais do
berce. Vou vir aqui, vou pegar, sei lá,
ã,
vamos pegar aqui o cursors.
Deixa eu pegar como é que ele tá aqui o
design dele. Vou pegar o cursor.
Copiei.
Botar aqui. Vou alterar aqui o design
[limpando a garganta]
instructions dele.
Salvar.
Agora vou pedir para alterar.
Vamos atualizar
todas as telas para o novo design. MD
que está nas suas instruções.
Vamos ver. Acho que isso aqui vai ser o
suficiente. Ele vai ler instruções de
novo e vai refazer. Senão eu colo aqui o
desenho TD. Agora ele vai refazer com
aquela tela preta que eu mostrei para
vocês, né?
Ah, bom. Basicamente qualquer coisa
vocês podem fazer agora com isso aqui
que eu acabei de passar para vocês.
Perceberam isso, né? O poder disso aqui.
Agora dentro do loveball é a mesma
coisa, né? Vou criar aqui um dashboard
dentro do Lovbow do cursor.
Ou melhor, é, vou criar o do cursor
mesmo, ó. Vem aqui, digito assim: "Quero
criar um
dashboard.
Ah,
sobre claro, o ideal aqui, eu tô só
fazendo para vocês ah demonstrações, né?
Não é assim que eu crio algo. Eu eu
digito uma frase, eu faço pesquisa,
tipo, eu crio um PRD, lembra? Lembram,
né, do da minha da minha lá da da minha
aula que eu dei para vocês, né? Eu nunca
venho aqui e jogo para ele um negócio,
sabe? Eu sempre vou fazer uma análise
antes, vai ter pesquisa, eu vou usar,
daí eu uso, eu uso para essa parte, né?
Então o X vai fazer toda a análise de
pesquisa, vou fazer, vou chamar o
arquiteto, vou construir todo, todo o
planejamento do projeto.
Eh, e por onde eu começo, tá? Ah, o
planejamento de um projeto, eu não
começo pelo design, eu começo pelos
dados. Então, eu analiso quais dados eu
vou extrair, quais dados os dados
iniciais.
Depois eu venho para cá. Ah, então isso
aqui que eu tô mostrando para vocês é só
demonstração do quanto é poderoso o
design. MD. Isso é é algo didático
mostrando para vocês. Não é o processo
correto você começar assim, né?
E por que que eu vou dizer isso? Se você
quer, ah, mas eu quero ver como é que
vai ser o design para eu poder pensar
mais sobre isso, tudo bem. Mas entenda
que é um rascunho, porque se você não se
começa pelo design, se começa pelos
dados, porque tudo é manipulação de
dados, né? E quando digo manipulação, tô
falando da palavra, eh, não tô da forma
eh,
não é que eu vou dizer, né, abst eh
pejorativa de manipulação, né?
Manipulação é você manipular mãos onde
você vai ter uma ação de modificar.
Então, tudo que tu tá criando sempre é
sobre modificar, transformar dados. Tudo
na vida é assim, né? Agora começo
filosófico aqui, mas se for pensar, a
vida é isso, né? A vida é manipulação.
Nada se cria, tudo se recria, tudo é
manipulação ah de matéria. Não, o que
que é matéria? Matéria é dados também.
Então, no fundo, tudo é sobre modificar
dados. Se você quando consome uma
banana, que tava ali mostrando a
bananinha, que que tá acontecendo? Ela
tá sendo digerida pelo teu organismo e
virando outros componentes que vão
depois alimentar tuas células, vão
virar, vai virar o que é você. Você é o
que come, né? Então tudo na vida,
inclusive na parte web e na parte de
criação de qualquer coisa é sobre dados.
Então por onde tu começa? Eu sempre
começo por análise de dados. Depois que
eu fiz análise de dados, eu vou para
análise de como esses dados vão ser
ajustados. Depois eu vou pensar em como
é que eles vão ser apresentados. Então,
por isso que eu nem gosto, eu sou um
cara que entende muito sobre design, mas
eu não gosto de de criar coisas web. Por
que, Alon? Porque
a gente se distrai com isso aqui, com um
botãozinho, com iconezinho, porque o
verdadeiro poder tá aqui, ó. Por isso
que eu gosto de código. Eu gosto de
olhar para isso aqui, né? Eu sou um cara
que veio do mundo de design e que hoje
não gosta de Eu só trabalho assim. Ah,
eu só trabalho olhando para tela preta o
dia todo. Por quê? Porque eu eu prefiro
olhar para isso aqui. Tipo assim, eu já
tá aqui as informações que eu preciso.
Eu eu clico aqui e tem as informações
que eu preciso. Mas
e por que que é interessante daí vocês
entenderem isso? que o design ele vem
para encapsular e facilitar a abstração
de informações para que o usuário
consiga
entender aquela informação e fazer algo
com ela. Então o design ele tem um fim
de utilidade, utilidade
e depois ele vai ter seu fim que é de
cosmético, né? Que é essa parte, nossa,
como é bonito isso. O quão é bonito isso
tem que ficar em último lugar. No
sentido de quê? Porque você pode fazer
um site super bonito que não é
funcional. Você pode fazer um sistema
que é bonito, mas que ninguém usa. Então
não adianta pensar no bonito. Gente, eu
tava lá na eu tava lá dentro da Gens
Park. A Gens Park vai bater 1 bilhão de
dólares.
Ah, e eles me falaram lá, né? Tava lá
com a Mariana, que é a brasileira que
cuida de comunidade lá lá dentro do
escritório deles em São Fran, eh, em
Palo Alto.
[roncando]
Eles não tend system. Eh, eles têm, pode
ver, é feio mesmo. É feio para caramba o
sistema deles. Hã,
eles não têm design system, eles têm um
monte de engenheiro programador lá que
fica criando aqui as funcionalidades.
Pode ver, é feio para caramba. Eles vão
bater 1 bilhão de dólares.
Eles têm o quê? Eles eles entendem muito
sobre ah growth, foi o que eles fizeram
aqui, vários várias formas de growth
aqui mesmo, né? Eles estão fazendo um
growth aqui, High Your employee. Aí eles
criaram o G Spark Claw, que é tipo um
open claw do GPK.
Ele só bugado mesmo. Esse cara aqui tá
cheio de bug, mas ele sobem bugado
porque eles vão inferindo, né? Isso é
uma é uma é uma regra do Vale, digamos
assim. Uma regra que eu mesmo uso para
mim há muito tempo mesmo, sem saber que
era do Vale, que é ship fast, interact
faster, né? Tipo assim, entregue, joga
rápido pra galera e interage mais
rápido.
>> [música]
[música]